hi herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr dabei seid wir sind
heute ein bisschen früher dran als sonst
denn die ehemalige Bundeskanzlerin
Angela Merkel wird heute mit der
höchstmöglichen Auszeichnung
Deutschlands geehrt und zwar mit dem
Großkreuz des bundesverdienstordens in
besonderer Ausführung und das wird die
gleich vom Bundespräsidenten Frank
Walter Steinmeier im Schloss Bellevue
verlieren und da sind wir für euch
natürlich mit ZDF heute live dabei
vormerkel erhielten dieses
Verdienstkreuz bislang nur die
ehemaligen Bundeskanzler Konrad Adenauer
und Helmut Kohl ist also eine ganz schön
große Sache und vielleicht erinnern sich
einige von euch noch in den 16 Jahren in
den Merkel Bundeskanzlerin war da ist
ganz schön viel passiert die Finanzkrise
der Atomausstieg eine enge Energie
Zusammenarbeit mit Russland die
natürlich im heutigen Kontext besonders
diskutiert wird die sogenannte
flüchtlingskrise und es gibt auch
durchaus kritische Stimmen zu dieser
Ordensverleihung an Merkel auf diese
Verleihung auf die Rede von Frank-Walter
Steinmeier auf das Merkel Vermächtnis da
sehen wir schon den noch leeren Saal im
Schloss Bellevue aber auch auf die
Kritik daran auf das alles wollen wir
heute schauen und mit euch gemeinsam die
Frage diskutieren hat Angela Merkel
diesen Orden den eigentlich verdient und
das mache ich wie immer nicht alleine
mit dabei sind ZDF hauptstadtkurs von
Dentin Nicole Diekmann und Journalisten
und Merkel biographin dr Ursula
Weidenfeld und natürlich auch ganz
wichtig wie immer ihr seid auch dabei
wenn ihr Fragen habt oder eure Meinung
zum Thema mit uns teilen wollt dann
schreibt uns einfach hier im Youtube
Chat oder per Mail an ZDF heute - live
at zdf.de jetzt sprechen wir aber
erstmal mit meiner ZDF Kollegin in
Berlin Nicole Diekmann hallo Nicole
hallo
Nicole ich habe es gerade schon gesagt
diese Auszeichnung haben vorher nur zwei
Bundeskanzler in Deutschland bekommen
wie bedeutend ist denn diese
Auszeichnung was hat die für eine
Signalwirkung
ja das ist eine wahnsinnig bedeutende
Auszeichnung du hast das gerade schon
gesagt vor ihr ging die an zwei
Politiker bevor sie jetzt heute an
Angela Merkel geht nämlich an Konrad
Adenauer und an Helmut Kohl weil das
Männer beides CDU-Politiker interessant
ist an
diesem Orden den Angela Merkel heute
bekommt unter anderem der Zeitpunkt denn
so lange ist ja noch gar nicht aus dem
Amt das sind gerade mal ungefähr 18
Monate die sie nicht mehr
Bundeskanzlerin ist das ist auch wäre
sie nicht 16 Jahre lang Regierungschefin
gewesen eine kurze Zeitspanne darauf
speist sich ein Teil der Kritik dass die
Leute sagen na ja 18 Monate so schnell
nachdem sie das Amt abgegeben hat bzw
nachdem das Amt dann ja auch in die
Hände der SPD an Olaf Scholz
übergegangen ist warum so schnell warum
so früh das ist das eine Signal dass
davon ausgeht und das kritisiert wird
das andere ist von wem bekommt Angela
Merkel diesen Orden das ist Frank-Walter
Steinmeier der ist nicht nur
Bundespräsident sondern der war auch
zweimal in Merkels Kabinetten nämlich im
ersten und im dritten von insgesamt
Vieren Außenminister und da sind wir
noch mal beim Zeitpunkt es tobt ein
Krieg es tut ein Krieg Russlands gegen
die Ukraine und Frank Walter Steinmeier
gilt ebenso natürlich wie Angela Merkel
als ein Architekt der jahrelangen
russland-politik der Bundesrepublik der
mittlerweile sehr kritisch gesehen wird
auch unter anderem von den damals
Beteiligten wie zum Beispiel Frank
Walter Steinmeier der vor kurzem erst
eingeräumt hat da habe man sich zu sehr
darauf verlassen es bei Wladimir Putin
mit einem rechtschaffenden Partner zu
tun zu haben auf dessen versprechen man
sich verlassen können deshalb auch viel
Kritik an diesem Orden in diesen Zeiten
na jetzt fragen sich viele von euch
bestimmt schon Orden da habe ich jetzt
noch gar nicht so viel von gehört was
gibt es denn da eigentlich für
Auszeichnungen und das hat sich mein
Kollege Thomas gonsi Oma für uns
angeschaut
wenn der Bundespräsident Verdienstorden
verleiht umgangssprachlich
Bundesverdienstkreuze dann ehrt er damit
Menschen die fürs Gemeinwohl Besonderes
leisten hier zum Beispiel Ehrenamtliche
und Helfer während der corona-pandemie
sie erhielten wie meist bei
erstauszeichnungen die Verdienstmedaille
oder das Verdienstkreuz am Bande weitere
höhere Stufen sind das Verdienstkreuz
erster Klasse und das Große
Verdienstkreuz erweitert mit Sternen und
mit Schulterband dieses große Verdienst
Kreuz erhielten z.B die russische
Menschenrechtlerin Ludmilla Alexa war
und die chemie-nobelpreisträger Stefan
hell die höchste Ehrung ist das
Großkreuz höchste Variante das Großkreuz
in besonderer Ausführung alle Orden
werden seit 1951 verlieren bisher mehr
als
262.000 mal die höchste Variante aber be
bisher nur zwei Menschen Konrad Adenauer
und Helmut Kohl und jetzt als Dritte im
höchst exklusiven Kreis
ex-kanzlerin Angela Merkel
[Musik]
und jetzt haben wir gerade schon gehört
vorher waren das zwei Politiker die das
bekommen haben unter anderem Adenauer
und der hat das noch während seiner
Amtszeit bekommen Nicole du hast ja
gerade gesagt das ist eigentlich ein
recht schneller Schuss jetzt Angela
Merkel dass ca 16 Monate nach dem Ende
ihrer Amtszeit zu verleihen wieso
bekommt denn dann jemand wie Adenauer
das noch während der Amtszeit
das ist eine gute Frage
eben die umgedrehte stellen sich ja
jetzt viele wir wollen dabei nicht
vergessen dass es auch viele
Unterstützer gibt für diesen Orden den
Angela Merkel heute bekommt aber eben
das ist die Frage die viele Kritiker
sich stellen und da gibt es eine These
die diskutiert wird dass Frank Walter
Steinmeier mit diesem Orden nicht nur
die Verdienst der altkanzlerin würdigen
will sondern auch ein bisschen
seine eigene ja stark kritisierte
Russlandpolitik als damals Außenminister
naja sagen wir mal ein wenig aus der
Kritik herausnehmen möchte noch mal es
gibt viele Befürworter worden fällt
nicht vom Himmel dafür muss Angela
Merkel ja auch vorgeschlagen worden sein
aber es gibt eben auch diese Kritik eben
nicht nur an Angela Merkel sondern auch
Anfang weiter Steinmeier der in zwei
ihrer Kabinette ihre vierkabinette als
Außenminister maßgeblich zu Russland
Politik zu Russland liegen ja ähm der
Bundesregierung damals
verantwortlich war
ja du hast schon angesprochen es gibt
Befürworter dieser verlangen heute es
gibt aber auch Kritiker wir haben unter
anderem schon den Zeitpunkt der
Verleihung angesprochen Frank Buchwald
hat noch einige andere Kritikpunkte von
zusammengetragen
das Großkreuz des bundesverdienstordens
mit Stern und Schulterband in besonderer
Ausführung
zu viel der Ehre sagen Kritiker wenn
Frank-Walter Steinmeier seiner alten
Chefin diesen Orden verleiht beweist er
nicht nur Angela Merkel und die Probleme
ihrer Ära sondern auch sich selbst und
ich glaube das ist ein Akt der
verantwortungslosen Ignoranz der der
Glaubwürdigkeit der Demokratie schadet
Probleme ihre Ära damit ist auch ihre
Außenpolitik gemeint verglüht in den
Trümmern ukrainischer Städte viel zu
lange habe Merkel den Worten Putins
vertraut nicht nur in Minsk kritisiert
Röder selbst CDU Mitglied das ist in der
Tat ein kapitaler außenpolitischer
Fehler gewesen vor dessen Scherben die
deutsche Politik heute steht Mensch hat
verhindert über Jahre das ist zum
Ausbruch des Krieges gekommen ist
übrigens steht die Ukraine heute
werfähig da was sie 2014 gar nicht
gewesen wäre nur wenige treten so wie
Armin Laschet für Merkel in die Bresche
bei der CDU vielstimmiges Schweigen
keine Kritik aber eben auch kein Lob und
getreue die um gute Worte Ringen wirken
etwas bemüht sie ist immer die Patente
Frau geblieben als die sie ganz jung
1990 daran werde ich mich immer lebhaft
erinnern beim vereinigungsparteitag der
CDU
für viele überraschend zur
stellvertretenden Parteivorsitzenden
gewählt wurde das Schweigen rührt
vielleicht auch von einer Energiepolitik
voller Widersprüche erst wollte Merkel
Atomkraft als Brückentechnologie
erhalten der Ausstieg aus dem Ausstieg
dann nach Fukushima ihre hastige
Energiewende zurück zur Kohle bis die
klimaproteste 2019 sie auch hier zum
Ausstieg zwangen Merkel als getriebene
wie 2015 in der flüchtlingskrise der
posierte sie gerne für selfies ließ sich
für humanitäre Gesten feiern auf die
Integration der Menschen aber war das
Land nicht vorbereitet ich bin erstmal
sehr zufrieden dass man Leute im Not
auch aufnehmen kann und das Deutschland
auch bereit war diese Menschen
aufzunehmen was aber Merkel ihre
Regierung und wir als Gesellschaft nicht
verstanden haben was wollen wir
eigentlich schaffen was wollen wir wie
wollen wir diese Leute erreichen auf
Kritik aber reagierte Merkel damals
genervt
wenn wir jetzt anfangen uns noch
entschuldigen zu müssen dafür dass wir
in Notsituationen ein freundliches
Gesicht zeigen dann ist das nicht mein
Land wenn man eine Persönlichkeit
beurteilt muss man das aus dem
jeweiligen Moment tun und nicht im
Nachhinein alles besser wissen
aber es geht ja doch um einen Orden den
höchst zu mal und die Kritik wurzelt
sehr viel tiefer
Angela Merkels Politik der
Alternativlosigkeit hat eine Entwicklung
der demokratischen Kultur in Deutschland
befördert in der nicht mehr die Vielfalt
der unterschiedlichen Meinungen zählt
die in einem Wettstreit miteinander
stehen sondern indem es nur noch die
eine Wahrheit gibt nämlich die eigene
[Musik]
auf Merkels Schreibtisch im Kanzleramt
stand eine Zeit lang ein kleines Porträt
die russische Zarin Katharina die Große
deren Kanzler hieß Patientin der Legende
nach der Erfinder der potjem kindischen
Dörfer ein Schelm der Böses dabei denkt
ja und da waren einige inhaltliche
Punkte dabei ich glaube aber viele da
draußen fragen sich wahrscheinlich
gerade hä das sind ja auch Menschen aus
der CDU die gerade Merkel da scharf
kritisieren Nicole kannst du uns
erzählen warum das in den Partei eigenen
Reihen so ein gemischtes Bild ist wir
haben zum einen den Laschet ehemaliger
Kanzlerkandidat der Merkel lobt und
verteidigt dann aber auch CDU Mann Röder
der ganz schön harte Töne findet für
Frau Merkel
das ist die konsequente Weiterführung
dessen was schon zur Merkels Zeit als
Kanzlerin und nicht zu vergessen auch
CDU-Vorsitzender geschehen ist nämlich
die zunehmende Spaltung der CDU in die
sogenannten Merkel Jana zu denen Armin
Laschet auch erzählte und zu denjenigen
die Merkels Kurs als zu Umfrage
getrieben zu wenig konservativ zu weit
nach links gerückt kritisiert haben
interessant ist in dem Zusammenhang wir
haben gerade sehr harte Kritik im
Beitrag gehört von Andreas der schreibt
gerade zusammen mit Karsten Linnemann
der die verlangung des Ordens an Merkel
heute auch kritisiert hat am neuen
Grundsatzprogramm der CDU das sind
beides
Betreuer kann man sagen des neuen
Parteichefs Friedrich Merz der heute
übrigens auch nicht dabei ist der sich
ähm als inhaltlicher Widersacher von
Angela Merkel früher ins Gespräch und
damit ja auch im dritten Anlauf an die
Spitze der CDU gebracht hat also diese
diese Polarisierung innerhalb der CDU wo
will man hin mehr in die Mitte weiter
nach rechts will ich nicht sagen aber
konservativer sein so konservativ sagen
einige wie man vormerkelszeiten war das
zieht sich bis heute durch
jetzt haben wir ja schon Angela Merkel
nach dem Ende der Amtszeit gar nicht
mehr so viel mitbekommen was hast du
denn mitbekommen als politische
Beobachterin wie hat sie sich zu den
inhaltlichen Vorwürfen bisher Verhalten
jetzt mal das Beispiel Energie Politik
in der sie ja stark die Nähe Russland
gesucht hat wo jetzt viele sagen na ja
russland hat die Ukraine angegriffen das
war aus dem politisch einfach nicht
wahnsinnig schlau
insgesamt hat sie sich stark
zurückgehalten in den letzten Monaten
seitdem sie von der politischen Bühne
abgetreten ist da sieht man ganz andere
ehemalige Parteivorsitzende zum Beispiel
Sigmar Gabriel in der SPD der sich bis
heute ja sehr aktiv einbringt und sehr
kritisch zum Teil in den Debatten die
auch innerhalb seiner Partei geführt
werden es gab einen Auftritt von einer
geiler Merkel hier in Berlin in Berliner
Ensemble da war im Grunde ihre Resümee
an diesem Abend auf die Fragen das
Journalisten des Spiegels der sie
interviewt hat dass sie eigentlich alles
richtig gemacht hat da war wenig zu
hören von Selbstkritik und ansonsten was
man im Moment vernimmt sitzt sie an
ihrem Buch dass sie zusammen mit ihrer
ehemaligen Büroleiterin die heute Abend
übrigens auch dabei ist schreibt darauf
schauen wir jetzt alle sehr gespannt
weil ansonsten wirklich wenig von ihr zu
hören ist sie hält sich in der
Öffentlichkeit komplett zurück
ich werfe hier gerade mal so ein Blick
in die Kommentare eure Meinung zum Thema
gehen auf jeden Fall auseinander hier
schreibe Joan Luc Picard auf Youtube
Respekt für Frau Merkel leider haben wir
inspirierende und zukunftsweisen Ideen
gefehlt sie hat sich eher mit verwalten
bückt aber Andreas Hoffmann auf Facebook
sagt natürlich hat Frau Dr Merkel diesen
Orden verdient das Renommee das
Deutschland in der Welt genießt ist zu
großen Teilen ihr verdient und da sind
wir auch direkt bei einer Frage aus der
Community nämlich zur Begründung dieser
Verleihung Matthias Koch schreibt auf
YouTube wird eigentlich kommuniziert
weshalb genau respektive für welche
Leistungen diese Auszeichnung verlieren
wird
naja was jetzt nicht passieren wird ist
das ähm kommuniziert wird wir beheben
besonders ihre Flüchtlingspolitik hervor
oder ihre Dienste und die
Arbeitslosenquote
was was dahinter steckt sind besondere
Verdienste besondere Verdienste so
allgemein wird das gefasst
um das deutsche Volk aber es gibt ja
gleich eine Rede des Bundespräsidenten
vielleicht wissen wir danach mehr was
ihn dazu bewogen hat dazu bewegt ihr
heute Abend diesen außerordentlichen
Abend zu verleihen
hast du denn jetzt in den letzten Tagen
oder das steht ja auch schon einige Tage
jetzt fest dass dieser Orden verliehen
wird hast du noch andere Reaktionen aus
dem politischen Berlin vielleicht nicht
nur aus der CDU wie hat die Hauptstadt
darauf reagiert
es gibt ein sehr prägnantes Zitat der
Linken Chefin Janine Wissler die spricht
von Lametta dass man wie einem
Weihnachtsbaum quasi in Form eines
Ordens heute Angela Merkel Umhängen
würde und sie das sehr in Zweifel ob das
überhaupt der richtige Weg ist und zumal
sie die Politik von Angela Merkel
kritisiert die habe zur sozialen
Spaltung weiter beigetragen andere Töne
kommen aus der SPD und von den Grünen
ähm sowohl SPD-Chefin Saskia esken kann
diesen Schritt heute nachvollziehen
ist doch mit lobenden Worten heute
zitiert worden in der Presse für Angela
Merkel und auch der Grünen Chef und mit
nur hält das für den richtigen Weg was
die AFD dazu sagt können wir uns denken
merkel muss weg war während Merkels
Amtszeit ein quasi Schlachtruf auf AFD
Veranstaltungen da ist natürlich die
einhellige Meinung dass Merkel diesen
ordentlich verdient hat das würde aber
für jeden anderen Politiker für jeder
andere Politikerin der anderen Parteien
ebenso gelten die für Angela Merkel
wir haben es gerade schon immer so ein
bisschen angesprochen wir sehen ja auf
dem Livebild weiterhin viele Lehre
Stühle und haben auch schon gehört dass
aus der aktuellen cdu-leitung niemand da
sein wird Nicole weißt du ein bisschen
wer da heute abend geladen ist also was
für Menschen da heute zuhören
genau es gibt eine Gästeliste und die
bestätigt diese Merkel Jana diese
Spaltung der CDU denn wenn man sich
anguckt wer aus der CDU heute Abend
dabei ist ist das niemand der in der CDU
jetzt noch eine Rolle spielt geschweige
denn zum Teil zumindest ähm in der
aktiven Politik es ist zum Beispiel
Thomas de Maizière immer ein enger
Vertrauter Angela Merkels unter anderem
war er buntes Innenminister zu ihrer
Regierungszeit oder Faller
Kanzleramtsminister unter Merkel Helge
braun der denselben Job unter anderem
inner hatte in ihrer letzten Amtszeit
Peter Altmaier ehemaliger
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Annette waren
die als enge Freundin von Angela Merkel
gilt die Bundesbildungsministerin war
und außerdem ich habe es eben schon
angesprochen ihre ehemalige Büroleiterin
ist heute Abend dabei Beate Baumann ihre
Medienberaterin Eva Christiansen und
ihre regierungssprecher Steffen Seibert
das heißt da sind heute Abend ist kein
einziges Mitglied des aktuellen
cdu-parteivorstandes geschweige denn der
Parteichef Friedrich Merz das sind alles
enge Weggefährten die schon zu Zeiten
Angela Merkels im Kanzleramt eng an
ihrer Seite waren und daran scheint sich
wenig geändert zu haben
ja mega spannend danke Nicole für diese
ersten Einblicke ich denke wir sprechen
uns gleich noch mal wir warten weiterhin
darauf dass diese Verleihung losgeht und
können aber schon mit einer anderen Frau
sprechen die das politische Treiben von
Angela Merkel sehr genau beobachtet hat
und das ist die Merkel Biografin und
Journalistin dr Ursula Weidenfeld hallo
Frau Weidenfeld schön dass Sie bei uns
sind
hallo
wie blicken sie denn auf diese
Verleihung heute abend Merkel ist ja
immer als eine sehr unprätentiöse
Politikerin beschrieben worden ähm
glauben sie dass Frau Merkel sich über
so eine Verleihung freut
das glaube ich schon also sie hat mit 16
Jahren Kanzlerin geschafft in einer
Reihe dazu stehen mit den beiden großen
konservativen Kanzlern Adenauer und cool
das gefällt dir glaube ich sehr sehr gut
also ob die jetzt unbedingt in Ordnung
gebraucht hätte mit Hand bestickt und
Lorbeerkranz das weiß ich nicht aber
dass sie da in einer Reihe steht mit den
großen Kanzlern ja nicht mit den großen
oder ist ja nicht explizit mit den
großen Parteivorsitzenden das tut mir
glaube ich gut
jetzt ist ja viel Kritik laut geworden
nach dem Ende der Amtszeit von Angela
Merkel wir gucken da auf eine Augen
vieler verfehlte Russlandpolitik auf
eine mittlerweile abgewendete
Abhängigkeit von russischem Gas es wird
immer wieder die sogenannte
flüchtlingskrise erwähnt wie gucken sie
denn auf das politische Vermächtnis von
Angela Merkel heute sehen Sie diese
Verleihung auch so kritisch wie einige
in der eigenen Partei
nee ich finde man muss schon auch gönnen
können und das da eine Kanzlerin regiert
hat 16 Jahre lang und bei aller Kritik
die jeder hat die ich auch habe und ich
teile auch eine ganze Menge von dem was
Andreas Reuter gerade gesagt hat bei
einer Kritik muss man doch respektieren
und anerkennen dass 16 Jahre eine enorme
Leistung sind physisch aber eben auch
intellektuell Angela Merkel war der
Stabilitätsanker der europäischen und
zeitweilig auch der internationalen
Politik das muss man einfach sehen und
im Inneren hat sie die Krisen die wir
erlebt haben sehr sehr anständig regiert
durch regiert und gelöst nicht gerade
die Ukraine und die russlandfrage das
ist eins der ein ein oder ist ein Teil
des Vermächtnis ist der zu recht
kritisch kommentiert wird aber im Großen
und Ganzen bei allen bei aller Kritik
auch bei aller Kritik am Regierungsstil
und an der Frage hätte ich ein paar mehr
Inhalte auch gut getan muss man glaube
ich schon sagen dass es auch vernünftig
ist ja jemandem dann einen guten und
einen würdigenden Abschied zu gehen
wir haben hier eine Frage wenn ich das
noch sagen darf natürlich nur noch ganz
ganz kurz
Adenauer und Kohl haben beide den Orden
in ihrer Amtszeit bekommen und zu fragen
ist es der richtige Zeitpunkt da würde
ich eben auch sagen ja das muss man
diskutieren ich würde auch sagen lieber
sofort oder 10 Jahre später jetzt ist so
eine blöde Zwischenzeit aber im Prinzip
verdient ja
wir haben auch direkt eine Frage aus der
Community zu dem Thema und zwar fragt
Tim Graser auf Youtube man kann ja auch
bei Adenauer und cool viel kritisieren
ist das jetzt nur konsequent weil Merkel
auch so lange regiert hat also die Frage
die dahinter steht ist ja ist das
explizit eine
Ordensverleihung die vor allem an
Menschen geht die sehr sehr lange
bestimmend in der deutschen Politik sind
ich meine z.B Gerhard Schröder hat diese
Auszeichnung ja nicht bekommen
ja könnte man so sehen dass das so eine
Art sitzprämie ist wo jeder der mehr als
12 Jahre jeder mehr als drei
Legislaturen geschafft hat der kriegt
den das stimmt aber nicht weil Konrad
Adenauer hat ihn bekommen kurz nachdem
er erfunden war das war am Ende seiner
ersten Amtszeit da musste der
Bundespräsident weiter ein paar Minister
schon ausgezeichnet hatte noch eine
extra Kategorie erfinden damit der
Kanzler eine Nummer höher ist also
damals waren ja schon alle noch sehr
Form und sehr Hierarchie bewusst und
deshalb hat er den schon praktisch nach
vier Jahren bekommen also es ist nicht
die sitzprämie als die das heute
verspottet wird es ist natürlich schon
auch ein ein eine Würdigung einer langen
Amtszeit jedenfalls bei Frau Merkel ich
nehme auch anders der Bundespräsident
das gleich sagen wird weil man eben
diese ganz großen Nummern wie deutsche
Einheit wie westbindungen also Gründung
der Bundesrepublik und Westbindung bei
Angela Merkel natürlich nicht finden
wird
ja darauf dass der
Bundespräsident diesen ordentlich darauf
warten wir weiterhin es gibt weiterhin
noch keine Gäste im Saal die wir da
sehen können aber wir erwarten jetzt
einfach mal dass er in den nächsten
Minuten
da im Saal zu sehen sein wird ich habe
ja eben mit meiner Kollegin Nicole
Diekmann auch darüber gesprochen über
darüber dass jetzt eben der
Bundespräsident Frank Walter Steinmeier
diesen Preis übergibt der eben auch
quasi seiner ehemaligen Chefin einen
Orden verleihen muss er war ja wie wir
gehört haben zweimal Außenminister im
Kabinett Merkel und hat ja damit auch
eine große Rolle in diesem Feld was eben
gerade so kritisiert wird wie bewerten
sie denn dieses Verhältnis das jetzt der
Bundespräsident seiner ehemaligen Chefin
diesen Orden verleiht mir das für
problematisch oder ist das einfach ganz
normale Praxis
naja das ist schon ein bisschen komisch
nicht wenn der frühere unterling jetzt
der Chef von Deutschland ist und seiner
früheren Chefin einen Orden gibt das
sieht immer schon ein bisschen komisch
aus aber auch das ist jetzt echt nicht
ungewöhnlich helmut Kohl hat seinen von
Horst Köhler bekommen nee von Hohmann
Entschuldigung von Roman Herzog bekommen
dem damaligen Bundespräsidenten
natürlich auch ein paar Teil von auch
jemand der Helmut Kohl auch viel
verdankt hat insofern ist es nicht
ungewöhnlich dass Frank Walter
Steinmeier als Bundespräsident die
Kanzlerin auszeichnet das ist ein
bisschen schief aussieht zu mal eben
Anfang Walter Steinmeier sicher schon
ausführlich entschuldigt hat für seine
Russland Politik das hat Nicole die man
ja eben auch schon erwähnt während
Angela Merkel ist noch nicht getan hat
und wahrscheinlich auch nicht so
existiert tun wird das macht das alles
in so einem kleinen bisschen
unangemessen aktuelles Licht der
Verdienstorden ist ja etwas was über der
Zeit stehen soll insofern das sicherlich
ein kleines Problem aber ich würde jetzt
mal sagen da muss das muss man nicht
überbewerten
da kam auf jeden Fall schon ein Fotograf
rein aber auf den haben wir nicht
gewartet ich habe hier noch eine Frage
aus der Community an sie und zwar fragt
angry Nerd auf Youtube inwiefern spielte
vermutlich Merkels Rolle auf
europäischer Ebene auch vor der
Euro-Krise wenn es um das Engagement um
die EU Verfassung ging eine Rolle das
ist ja ein Punkt der wird jetzt im
Nachhinein nicht mehr so viel diskutiert
ja und ich finde das falsch also ich bin
super dankbar angry Nerd für diese Frage
weil ich glaube das wirklich eine der
ganz großen Leistungen von Angela Merkel
tatsächlich dieses dieses europäische
Moment ist was man im Moment unter
spielt und wo man auch immer gesagt hat
Mensch der macron der ist so viel cooler
und so viel charismatischer das ist
falsch das zu tun Angela Merkel hat mit
ihrer Politik Europa zusammengehalten
zuletzt als griechenland hat den Euro
verlassen wollte das war eine Nacht in
der Angela Merkel im Grunde die Sache
gewuppt hat und das oder ist
ja und wir sehen jetzt da kommen auf
jeden Fall schon mal ein paar bekannte
Gesichter in den Saal wir sehen die
EU-Kommissionspräsident Präsidentin
Ursula von der Leyen wir haben eben
Peter Altmaier gesehen immer Ärger
Wirtschaftsminister und ich glaube da
geht es demnächst gleich los wir
behalten dass mal im Blick und haben
aber noch eine Frage aus der Community
vielleicht haben wir für die noch Zeit
das machen wir
wenn ich Frau Weidenfeld noch sehe und
höre da ist sie wunderbar eine schnelle
Frage noch und zwar fange Ismael 04 auf
Youtube liegt die Kritik an Merkel nicht
vor allem nach ihrer Amtszeit vor allem
daran was ihre Russlandpolitik betrifft
und nicht an ihrer Gesamtbilanz also
dieses Russland Thema ist ja gerade sehr
im Fokus geraten da vielleicht Dinge
außer sich die in den 16 Jahren auch
noch passiert sind
zwei Sachen sind da ganz wichtig das
eine ist Russland das ist eben einfach
eine Politik die ganz offensichtlich
jetzt gescheitert ist und wo man einen
neuen Ansatz finden muss und das zweite
ist eben die neue Regierung kehrt jetzt
aus und sagt an allem was schlecht war
ist Angela Merkel Schuld das dauert auch
noch ein paar Monate und wenn es vorbei
ist wird man auch wieder die Verdienste
sehen
und während wir über sie sprechen
Betrieb sie gerade den Saal und da kommt
auch unser Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz und
auch der Bundespräsident Frank Walter
Steinmeier ist jetzt da und beginnt
gleich zu reden fällt erstmal vielen
Dank bis hierhin und ich glaube wir
sprechen uns gleich noch mal bis gleich
Ciao sehr geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler
liebe Gäste meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren
wir alle hier erinnern uns an den Abend
des zweiten dezember
2021 es war dunkel
es war eiskalt es war der Tag an dem
eine beispiellose Politikerin
selbstbestimmt
Abschied von der politischen Bühne Namen
sie liebe Frau Merkel betraten das
Podest vor dem Bett im
Verteidigungsministerium
rechts und links neben ihnen standen an
jenem Abend für die meisten unerwartet
auch zwei große Vasen voller rote Rosen
das Wachbataillon der Bundeswehr war
angetreten um sie nach 16 Jahren als
Bundeskanzlerin mit dem Großen
Zapfenstreich zu verabschieden
man muss sich nur diesen Abschiedstag im
Amt ansehen
und vielleicht zu verstehen warum die
Menschen in unserem Land Ihnen über all
die Jahre ihr Vertrauen geschenkt haben
denn wie selbstverständlich gingen sie
auch an diesem Tag
noch ihre Arbeit als Regierungschefin
als der Zapfenstreich begann
waren sie gerade als geschäftsführende
Bundeskanzlerin von einer Konferenz mit
den ministerpräsidentinnen und
Ministerpräsidenten gekommen unser Land
befand sich mitten in der vierten Welle
der Pandemie undenkbar
dass Angela Merkel nur wegen ihrer
Abschiedszeremonie ihre Arbeit nicht
erledigt
auch an diesem Tag des Abschieds also
konnten die Deutschen zwei Dinge spüren
zwei Dinge die für ihre Amtszeit
kennzeichnet waren und die über so viele
Jahre dafür sorgten dass die wichtigste
politische Währung
das Vertrauen Bestand hatte erstens
auf ihre Kanzlerin und deren
Pflichtbewusstsein konnte man sich
verlassen und zweitens
die Kanzlerin stellte sich selbst als
Person
nie in den Mittelpunkt jede Eitelkeit
jedes manche lei jedes Getue um sie
selbst waren ihr zu wieder
und zurück zu den Rosen meine Damen und
Herren ja wir erinnern uns diese Rosen
hatten mit ihrer
Liedauswahl beim Zapfenstreich zu tun
aber
vielleicht doch mit noch etwas mehr denn
dass diese Rosen da standen irritierte
erst einmal
die eingefahrenen Sehgewohnheiten und
Routinen beim sehr männlichen
militärischen Zeremoniell des
Zapfenstreichs diese Rosen waren
vielleicht ein sichtbares Zeichen dass
hier die erste Kanzlerin verabschiedet
wurde ein Zeichen übrigens das zu Beginn
ihrer Amtszeit für viele
nicht denkbar gewesen wäre am Ende der
Zeremonie hielten sie liebe Frau Merkel
eine der Rosen in ihrer Hand das wirkte
so selbstverständlich
als sei es beim Zapfenstreich in
Deutschland nie anders gewesen
sie waren eben nicht nur die erste Frau
im Kanzleramt sie haben mit ihrer
kanzlerinnenschaft dafür gesorgt dass
eine Frau an der Spitze der Regierung
das auch weibliche Macht für immer
eine Selbstverständlichkeit in unserem
Land sein würde
sehr geehrte Frau Bundeskanzlerin liebe
Frau Merkel
die besondere Ausführung des großkretes
die ich Ihnen heute aushändigen darf
ist ein ausnahmeordnung er wird so
selten verliehen dass im ordenstadt TUT
zunächst nicht einmal sein konkretes
Aussehen beschrieben war zuletzt wurde
diese Auszeichnung vor 25 Jahren
vergeben an Helmut Kohl für seine
Verdienste um die Einheit unseres Landes
ich freue mich
heute nun Angela Merkel auf diese Weise
zu Ehren zu Ehren werde Frau
Bundeskanzlerin für ihre außergewöhnlich
lange Amtszeit für ihren
außergewöhnlichen politischen Lebensweg
auf dem sie die Erfahrung in der
Diktatur so überzeugend einsetzten für
die Stärkung der Demokratie
sie haben unserem Land unter nie
dagewesenen Herausforderungen neu zu
wirtschaftlichen erfolgverhalten wir
blicken zurück auf 16 Jahre mit nahezu
ununterbrochenem Wirtschaftswachstum in
denen die Geister der Arbeitslosigkeit
für die meisten Deutschen
ihren Schrecken mehr und mehr verloren
Pferde Frau Merkel wir wissen
mit unerwarteten Situationen damit
kennen sich aus und vielleicht noch
besser als die meisten Weggefährten die
sie in ihrer Amtszeit und auch dem Weg
dorthin umgeben haben
für sie fand der Umbruch im Osten eben
nicht nur in Schlagzeilen statt
wir haben es selbst in ihre Rede zum Tag
der Deutschen Einheit vor zwei Jahren
gesagt während für die meisten
westdeutschen die Wende bedeutete dass
im Wesentlichen alles weitergehen wie
bisher
veränderte sich für die Ostdeutschen
mit einem Schlag fast alles die
Gesellschaft
die Arbeitswelt
die Politik
als die Mauer fiel
waren sie 35 Jahre alt von heute aus
betrachtet
klingt es so einfach wenn man sagt sie
hatten sich damals entschlossen die
Freiheit die sie so lange entbehrt
hatten zu nutzen
dabei war es doch viel mehr so in einer
historischen Ausnahme Situation
hatten sie den Mut ins ungewissen ins
offene zu gehen
sind 16 Jahre später
als erste Bürgerin aus dem Osten ins
Kanzleramt gewählt worden und auch als
erste Frau
und sie stellten
beides nie in den Mittelpunkt aus ihrer
Sicht aus guten Gründen
sie mussten nicht nur zu Beginn ihrer
Amtszeit die bittere Erfahrung machen
wie verkürzen pauschalisieren
kenntnislos von oben herab
mitunter auf ostdeutsche Biografien und
auch auf Frauen in der Politik geschaut
wurde diese Erfahrung begegnet sie in
ihre Amtszeit wie ich finde pragmatisch
und klug sie machten die
Zurückhaltung im persönlichen
zu einer eigenen Stärke
geht es nicht alles ein bisschen schnell
so fragte sie der Journalist Günther
Gaus in seiner Sendung im Jahre 1991
zu diesem Zeitpunkt waren sie gerade
kurz davor
Vizevorsitzende der CDU zu werden und
damit in die Spitze einer Partei
aufzurücken in die sie ganz streng
genommen nicht einmal eingetreten war
im Dezember 1989 kurz nach dem Mauerfall
hatten sie sich dem demokratischen
Aufbruch angeschlossen der dann später
in der CDU aufging ein Vierteljahr
später
waren sie stellvertretende
Regierungssprecherin der DDR ein Jahr
darauf
hatten sie ein
Bundestagsmandat für die CDU in und
waren als Familienministerin die erste
ostdeutsche Frau in einer
Bundesregierung
für manch einen der an die
bundesrepublikanischen und sehr männlich
geprägten Regeln der politischen
Karriere gewöhnt war
war das ein bisschen viel eine
Naturwissenschaftlerin aus dem Osten
eine Frau
ohne etablierte Netzwerke ohne die
sogenannte Ochsentour ohne Hausmacht und
dann in einer sehr westdeutsch geprägten
Partei und dann auch noch so erfolgreich
in jener Phase mussten sie sich neben
allem anderen auch schnell an den
Umstand gewöhnen dass es kaum ein Rollen
Vorbild für sie gab sie mussten sich
ohne Vorbilder ohne Gesellschaft in
ihren Weg durchs parteipolitische
Unterholz suchen und Bahnen und das eben
auf ihre ganz eigene Art
vielleicht auch deshalb waren sie für
manchen meist männlichen Widersacher
einfach sehr schwer lesbar aber das
bereitete ihnen vermutlich keine
schlaflosen Nächte
sie gingen ihren Weg
manche und nicht nur die von der
politischen Konkurrenz dachten
vielleicht anfangs
dass ihre Zeit im Kanzleramt ein
intermez so sein wird manche gönnten
Ihnen die Aufgabe nicht andere trauten
sie ihnen nicht zu aus Unkenntnis aus
missguns aus Oberflächlichkeit
jedenfalls haben viele sie unterschätzt
wer sie aus der Nähe beobachtete oder
mit ihnen arbeitete
hatte einen ganz und gar gegenteiligen
Eindruck
da führte jemand eine Regierung mit
Ehrgeiz Selbstdisziplin
ja und scheinbar grenzenloser
Belastbarkeit auch offen für Beratung
und vor allen Dingen mit Neugier auf
Menschen will sagen
wer enger mit ihnen zu tun hatte oder
gemeinsam mit Ihnen im Kabinett saß
konnte sie gar nicht unterschätzen
das gilt im Übrigen wenn ich das sagen
darf auch für Wahlkampfzeiten mehr als
einem Kommentator fehlten in ihren
Wahlkämpfen das Schlachten Geschrei der
schwere Säbel das Kampfgetümmel in der
Arena
das war auch 2009 so als wir beide
gegeneinander antraten und ich gebe zu
dass auch mir damals tatsächlich die
harte Polarisierung schwer viel nicht
nur
weil es einiges gab was uns verbannt
sondern vor allem weil wir beide schon
vier Jahre gemeinsam
Regierungsverantwortung getragen hatten
dazu
nach 2008 in einer der schwersten
Wirtschaftskrisen die das Land bis dahin
erlebt hatte und natürlich prägt das
diejenigen Frau Merkel die sie
unterschätzen
haben sich ins Unrecht gesetzt denn sie
haben es bis zum Ende ihre Amtszeit
geschafft Deutschland als größte
Volkswirtschaft in Europa zu stärken das
war noch nie einfach aber
Ausnahmesituationen und Krisen reiten
sich in ihrer Amtszeit aneinander
überlagerten sich teilweise ich nenne
nur Limon Brothers Eurokrise Pandemie
und ich könnte weitere nennen
über den Umgang mit Krisen und den Wegen
aus ihnen heraus
wurde immer gestritten
zuweilen auch heftig
ich glaube nicht viele Länder haben
diese Phase so gut überstanden
wie die Bundesrepublik wie also ist
Ihnen Frau Merkel
das gelungen blicke ich auf das Rüstzeug
für ihre Politik fallen mir drei
herausragende Fähigkeiten ins Auge
erstens
wir beharren auf Fakten und ihre
Bereitschaft die Fakten zu durchdringen
zweitens die Kunst des Verhandelns und
ihre Fähigkeit zum Kompromiss und
drittens ihre Festigkeit ihre
Unbeirrbarkeit mit der sie
ganz grundsätzliche Prinzipien unsere
Staates hochhielten
für sie war es erstens unverzichtbar
zu wissen was Sache ist die
Herangehensweise der
WissenschaftlerInnen und der Kanzlerin
Angela Merkel war es
Probleme nüchtern zu analysieren
Argumente auseinanderzunehmen
[Musik]
die Dinge verstehen zu lernen für die
Entscheidung auch Möglichkeiten und auch
die Grenzen für Kompromisse auszurichten
ich habe einfach eine Modellrechnung
gemacht so begannen sie Frau Merkel als
sie auf einer Pressekonferenz in einer
sehr klaren Sprache erklärten wie sich
das Coronavirus exponentiell ausbreitet
man hätte damals bei einer denken können
einer virologin zuzuhören die auf den
Punkt kommt und sich nicht in
Allgemeinplätzen verlieren will
der Wissenschaft sind sie selbst
wissenschaftlich geschulten neugierig
und vorurteilsfrei begegnet vor
Entscheidungen
versuchten sie immer
möglichst wenig Unbekannte in ihrer
Gleichung zu haben das war aber gerade
während der Pandemie kaum oder nicht
möglich sie mussten sie Entscheidungen
unter ungewissheitsbedingungen treffen
bei
begrenzter Aussagefähigkeit und
Vorläufigkeit vorhandener Befunde
mussten sie die Rechnung mit vielen
Unbekannten machen und das heißt auch
getroffene Entscheidungen im Zweifel
einen neuen Erkenntnissen auch wieder
korrigieren
die Fakten klar zu haben das bedeutet
auch darauf zu reagieren wenn sich diese
ändern Entscheidungen anzupassen wenn
man merkt sie sind falsch
und das muss man können und sie Frau
Merkel sie konnten das als
Bundeskanzlerin ich will hinzufügen in
einer Demokratie ist Selbstkorrektur ein
hohes ich würde sagen unverzichtbares
Gut eines das im übrigen
Autokratien nicht kennen und dass wir
schon deshalb nicht
diskreditieren sollten
nicht zuletzt unter dem Eindruck der
Finanzmarktkrise haben sie die
Regulierung der Märkte und die die Rolle
des Staates auch des Sozialstaates neu
bewertet nach dem Reaktorunglück in
Fukushima haben sie den Ausstieg aus dem
Atomausstieg in ihrer eigene und damit
ihre eigene Regierungspolitik revidiert
selbst die sogenannte osterruhe in der
Pandemie ließen sich nennen als Sie wie
Sie gesagt haben einen Irrtum Zugaben
sich öffentlich sogar dafür
entschuldigten
vielleicht mögen das manche als Schwäche
gesehen haben aber es ist doch
eigentlich genau umgekehrt es ist eine
Stärke dass sie diese Kraft zur
Selbstkorrektur vorgelebt haben dass sie
eine Position oder Entscheidung die sich
im Verlaufe falsch oder überholt oder
schwer umsetzbar herausgestellt hat dass
sie die korrigiert haben auch das macht
glaube ich die Größe ihrer Kanzlerschaft
aus und war auch ein Grund
für die Dauer ihrer Amtszeit den gebürt
nicht nur mein persönlicher Respekt
sondern
erklärt viel von der Dankbarkeit viele
Menschen die sie über die weite Strecken
der Kanzlerschaft begleitet hat
die Sachlage hat sich auch verändert bei
einer der damals und heute größten
politischen Herausforderungen den
Beziehungen zu Russland
es ist das eine das Deutschland 2014
meinem Hilferuf des damaligen
ukrainischen Präsidenten folgte
tausenden Soldaten in der Ostukraine
drohte die Einkesselung bei debalze wo
vielleicht schlimmeres
sie Frau Merkel haben sich damals bis
zur Erschöpfung bemüht eine Ausweitung
des Krieges zum Flächenbrand in der
gesamten Ukraine zu verhindern und das
war nicht nur die ukrainische bitte es
war das Gebot der Stunde und es bleibt
richtig
dass Deutschland damals 2014 auf Wunsch
der Ukraine
sein Gewicht für ein
Waffenstillstandsabkommen und für
nachfolgende Verhandlungen sowie der
Herstellung der territorialen Integrität
der Ukraine in die werkschale gelegt hat
das andere
das andere ist der 24 Februar 2022
Russlands brutale Angriffskriege auf die
Ukraine
dieser Epochenbruch fordert von uns
allen neues Nachdenken
erzwingt uns Positionen zu überprüfen
das scheinbar und denkbare mitzudenken
und vor allem die Demokratie nach außen
nach innen zu stärken
Putins russland hat die europäische
sicherheitsordnung in Frieden auf
unserem Kontinent für den Sie wie viele
ihre Vorgänge im Kanzleramt Jahre und
jahrzehntelang gearbeitet haben in
Schutt und Asche gelegt
der 24 Februar 2022 hat nicht nur Europa
er hat die Welt verändert und damit auch
unseren Blick auf die Jahre deutscher
und europäischer Politik zuvor wichtig
ist
dass wir unsere Lehren daraus ziehen
heute müssen wir anders denken
an das Handeln und das tut unser Land
seit dem vergangenen Jahr mit großer
Entschlossenheit als mittlerweile größte
Unterstützer der Ukraine innerhalb der
Europäischen Union
verehrte Frau Merkel zu ihrem
Rüstzeug gehörte zweitens ihre Kunst des
Verhandelns ihre Fähigkeit zum
Kompromiss sie waren Europa und auch
weltweit als Meisterin in diesen Fächern
gerühmt sie sind regelmäßig gut
vorbereitet
in Verhandlungen gegangen sie kannten
die Positionen der anderen auch deren
Schmerzpunkte
sie hatten gute Nerven auch dann wenn
viele schon vom Scheitern redeten sie
konnten zuhören sie konnten mit Ungeduld
umgehen und auch mit dem Vorwurf sie
wurden zögern sie können es aushalten
sehr lange aushalten wenn man sie
deshalb dafür auch öffentlich mit Kritik
bedachte bisweilen sogar mit Häme
genauso oft
haben wir es aber gesehen wenn der
Moment gekommen war wenn etwas zu
entscheiden war besonders wenn etwas
schnell zu entscheiden war
dann waren sie da dann haben Sie zum
Beispiel die Ersparnisse der Bürgerinnen
und Bürger gemeinsam mit ihrem
Finanzminister verlaufender Kamera für
sicher erklärt in einer der schwersten
Krisen ihre Amtszeit der
Gleichzeitigkeit einer
finanzwirtschafts-
in dieser Krise war ihre
Verhandlungskunst ganz besonders gefragt
und ich denke man kann sagen auch
deshalb hat unsere gemeinsame
europäische Währung weiter bestand auch
deshalb sind wir mit blauem Auge aber
ohne bleibende Schäden durch die
Eurokrise gekommen durchaus
gegen Widerstand in Teilen der deutschen
Öffentlichkeit im Parlament und selbst
in der eigenen Partei
selbst gegen diesen Widerstand haben sie
dazu beigetragen dass der Euroraum
weiter besteht dass kein Land aus
unserer gemeinsamen Währung ausscheiden
musste
sie wussten immer wie wichtig es ist
Gesprächskanäle auch zu schwierigen
Partnern offen zu halten nicht auf den
Gesichtsverlust des Gegenübers zu setzen
um Europa beieinander zu halten
haben sie ganz bewusst auf den
Beifall vieler auch mancher politischer
Freunde verzichtet und das in einer Zeit
in der unser Kontinent auseinander zu
brechen drohte da haben sie Zentrum und
Peripherie den Norden und den Süden
Europas den Osten und den Westen
zusammengehalten übrigens das haben sie
auch mitten in der Pandemie geschafft
als vielen Ländern der Absturz drohte
und die Zustimmung einiger EU-Länder zu
einem corona-
Überzeugung mit das einige Deutschland
in einem geeinten Europa fest zu
verankern ist stellt sie ganz erkennbar
in die Tradition von Helmut Kohl auch
wenn sie in ihrer Regierungszeit noch
einmal ganz andere Herausforderungen nie
zuvor gekannte Krisen der europäischen
Einigung meistern muss
für unsere
wichtigsten außereuropäischen Partner
und Freunde die Vereinigten Staaten
waren sie über lange Zeit die
entscheidende Ansprechpartnerinnen in
Europa george w Bush und Barack Obama
haben sie in schwierigen Zeiten gar als
Führungsfigur der westlichen Welt des
freien Westens gerühmt und auch unter
Donald Trump gelang es ihnen wenigstens
im Dialog zu bleiben
sehr verehrte Frau Merkel für all das
braucht man
eine enorme Kondition
[Musik]
denn ungeheures Maß an Selbstdisziplin
ich darf wohl sagen dass ich nicht der
einzige bin der davor großen Respekt
hatte wenn wir beide nach langen
Sitzungen der europäischen Räte
weit nach Mitternacht müde und erschöpft
noch ein Presse Hintergrundgespräch
führten schien mir meine Sehnsucht nach
Schlaf meist ausgeprägter zu sein als
ihre
ich habe natürlich durchgehalten man
will sich ja keine Blöße geben
ich hatte erwähnt liebe Gäste zum
Rüstzeug und Frau Merkel gehört drittens
ihre Festigkeit wenn es galt
grundlegende Werte unsere Staates
hochzuhalten
als wir nach dem flüchtlingssommer 2015
bemerkten wie die Skepsis der Menschen
wuchs
Mitmenschlichkeit zu bröckeln begann
darstellten sie sich hin und sagten
wir schaffen das
ihnen wird ja oft nachgesagt dass sie
die Dinge vom Ende her denken
die Dimensionen der Fluchtbewegung aber
die konnte niemand vorhersehen
das konnten auch sie nicht vom Ende her
denken Sie haben diesen besonderen Satz
natürlich nicht einfach dahin gesagt
ihnen war sehr wohl klar
welche not die Menschen auf der
Balkanroute und dem Mittelmeer antreibt
und ihnen war genauso klar welche
Herausforderungen auf unsere Kommunen
zukommen um die geflüchteten
unterzubringen und zu integrieren dazu
führten sie noch Gespräche bis kurz
vor ihre Entscheidung die Grenzen
unseres Landes nicht zu schließen und
sicher hatten sie auch sie die Frage im
Kopf ob und wie lange es unsere Land
wohl aushalten würde
wenn direkt an unserer Grenze Menschen
zehntausende frieren
und hungern wenn ich an die Situation
damals denke
und darf es heute blicke dann meine ich
wir können sagen
vieles geschafft mit enormen
Anstrengungen und mit heftigen
Kontroversen
und niemand unterschätzt sie selbst am
wenigsten was noch zu tun bleibt
die Holocaust Überlebende rot-klüger die
2017 zum Tag des Gedenkens an die Opfer
des Nationalsozialismus im Deutschen
Bundestag sprach bezeichnete ihr berühmt
gewordenes wir schaffen das
als bescheiden anmutendes und dabei
heroisches wahlwort
stärker
kann man die Bedeutung dieser drei Worte
ich glaube kaum würdig
unbeirber und fest blieben sie Frau
Merkel auch in ihrem Eintreten für den
Schutz jüdischen Lebens in Deutschland
für die Entwicklung der Deutsch
israelischen Beziehungen
natürlich fällt uns allen jenes starke
weltweit beachtete Zeichen ein
welches sie mit ihrer Rede 2008 in der
Knesset setzen die Gaben des versprechen
dass die Sicherheit Israels für Sie als
deutsche Kanzlerin
niemals verhandelbar sein
ich habe ganz besonders großen Respekt
dafür
wie sie auch jenseits des hellen
Scheinwerferlicht solcher World News
beharrlich dafür gearbeitet haben
das jüdisches Leben in Deutschland eine
feste zukunftsfähige Grundlage mit
Kindergärten und Schulen mit einer
klaren Rechtslage
zur Religionsausübung und ja mit dem
leider immer wieder nötigen Schutz gegen
Antisemitismus Hass und tödliche Gewalt
in diesem Bemühen niemals nachzulassen
es hat uns verbunden
und für ihre Beharrlichkeit für ihre
Klarheit bin ich ihnen sehr dankbar und
unser Land muss es auch sein man kann es
kaum klarer formulieren als das Ronaldo
der Präsident des jüdischen
Weltkongresses gesagt hat bei der
Verleihung des Theo der herzel-preises
sind sie leider nannte sie ein
schutzfall ein schutzfall gegen
Instabilität Irrationalität
Extremismus Hass
und Antisemitismus werte Frau Merkel
dieses Rüstzeug ihres Zeug
das hat sie durch 16 Jahre Kanzlerin
Schaft getragen
aber für gute Politik
braucht man noch etwas zusätzlich
und zwar Zuversicht beim Großen
Zapfenstreich zu ihrem Abschied
nannten sie es die Fröhlichkeit im
Herzen und ich wünsche Ihnen
dass sie diese Fröhlichkeit im Herzen
immer behalten auch sehr viele
Bürgerinnen und Bürger dieses Landes das
weiß ich blicken mit Dankbarkeit auf
ihre Kanzlerschaft sie haben als Frau
und als Ostdeutsche das Amt noch einmal
neu geprägt
das bleibt
und der stiftet andere an politische
Verantwortung nicht zu scheinen auch
weil sie dabei einen Stil gepflegt haben
der der Sache
immer den Vorzug vor der
Selbstdarstellung gegeben hat
16 Jahre lang
haben sie Deutschland gedient mit
Ehrgeiz
Klugheit mit Leidenschaft
16 lange Jahre haben sie
für Freiheit und Demokratie für unser
Land und für das Wohlergehen seiner
Menschen gearbeitet
unermüdlich
und manchmal
bis an die Grenzen ihre körperlichen
Kraft
für ihre herausragenden Verdienste darf
ich Ihnen als Bundespräsident nun das
Großkreuz des Verdienstordens der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland in besonderer
Ausführung verleihen und darf sie dazu
nach vorne bitten
[Applaus]
zur Verleihung gehört das Verlesen der
Verleihungsurkunde
Verleihungsurkunde in Anerkennung der um
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
erworbenen außerordentlichen Verdienste
verleihe ich Frau Dr Angela Merkel
Bundeskanzlerin add das Großkreuz des
Verdienstordens der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland in besonderer Ausführungen
berlin den 17 April 2023 und des folgt
die Unterschrift des Bundespräsidenten
jetzt können Sie noch mal klatschen
[Applaus]
Bundespräsident
niemand muss erschrecken ich habe in
meiner Amtszeit gelernt und die
Regierungssprecher musste es oft sagen
wenn wir gefragt wurden was für von
dieser oder Jena Ausführung des
Bundespräsidenten halten hieß es immer
die Worte des Bundespräsidenten stehen
für sich und so ist es natürlich auch
heute ich möchte nur Danke sagen dafür
dass ich heute hier sein darf denn das
hat etwas mit ihrer Entscheidung zu tun
ich möchte den Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
danken dass er sich Zeit genommen hat
ich erinnere mich noch wage dass Zeit
ein knappes Gut ist und in diesen Zeiten
ganz besonders deshalb Dankeschön weil
es vielleicht auch etwas darüber sagt
dass wir immer versucht haben auch bei
Meinungsverschiedenheiten gut
zusammenzuarbeiten
ich durfte heute einige Leute
einladen die stehen natürlich nur
Passwort toto für so viele die mir
geholfen haben das was ich gearbeitet
habe oder was ich erreichen wollte auch
zu erreichen und die mich durch die
Zeiten getragen haben dazu zählen die
politischen Weggefährten
einer ist ein ganz früher reiner
Eppelmann denn er war mein Vorsitzender
im demokratischen Aufbruch wir sind
durch die große leidenzeit gegangen dass
unsere politischen Erwartungen bei der
ersten freien Volkskammer weil sich
nicht ganz so erfüllt hatten wie wir uns
das vorgestellt haben und deshalb danke
dass du hier bist
ich möchte Ursula von der Leyen danken
dass Sie sich Zeit genommen hat bei ihr
ist das mit dem knappen Gut ungefähr
genauso
Ursula von der Leyen und Annette Schavan
zwei Frauen die mir geholfen haben das
was als Frauen noch nicht vorgeprägt war
ein ganz unterschiedlicher Weise zu
leben durch dick und dünn auch wieder
mit ganz unterschiedlichen Eigenschaften
mir zu helfen und zur Seite zu stehen
danke dafür
und ich habe
als ich vor der Qual der Wahl stand aber
gerne und aus voller Überzeugung die
vier Männer eingeladen die meine
Kanzleramtsminister waren Thomas die mir
sehr der erste in der Riege 100
braun man kann sagen keiner hat länger
als vier Jahre ausgehalten ich kann aus
eigener Erfahrung sagen es ist ein
knüppeljob und ich bedanke mich für
unglaubliche Loyalität für unglaublichen
Einsatz und es war immer
gut dass wir toll miteinander
ausgekommen sind ich hatte zwei weitere
Personen gerne heute Abend hier begrüßt
Volker kauder-konto aus zeitlichen
Gründen nicht kommen er hat mich durch
dick und dünn auch was die Fraktion
anbelangt begleitet und Franz
Müntefering dem ich gute Gesundheit
Wünsche denn er war derjenige der zu mir
gesagt hat als ich drei Tage vor meiner
Vereidigung als Bundeskanzlerin 2005
doch etwas zittrige Beine bekam und
mulmiges Gefühl im Magen das wird schon
und das hat mir geholfen
ich habe für die Berater die mir so
viele so viel zur Seite standen
zwei Menschen eingeladen von den eine
Beate Baumann heute aus Gesundheitlichen
aber wirklich nur Viren außerhalb von
Corona toben sich im Augenblick in
Deutschland aus sie kennen das alle und
ich habe es auch so ein bisschen nicht
dabei sein kann aus diesem Grunde aber
Steffen Seibert und Eva Christiansen
sind hier drei aus sehr vielen die
geholfen haben aber diese drei standen
und Wochenende und immer
so dass man alles besprechen konnte
alles hin und her abwägen konnte und
dafür sage ich einfach aus voller
Überzeugung danke
dann ist einer hier Jürgen Klinsmann der
passt nicht so
ganz ins Konzept denn besonders
sportlich bin ich nicht aber ganz früh
als man von mir glaubte dass ich mich
für Fußball nicht interessiere und von
ihm glaubte dass er zu viel nach
Kalifornien reist sind wir zwei
unkonventionellen zusammengekommen und
haben uns eigentlich nie wieder aus den
Augen verloren er ist für mich der Mann
der zeigt was man alles bewegen kann und
das Sommermärchen ohne Jürgen Klinsmann
wer nicht denkbar
natürlich möchte ich meiner Familie ganz
herzlich danken schade dass meine Eltern
nicht mehr dabei sein können das wäre
schön gewesen aber ich freue mich dass
mein Bruder meine Schwester heute dabei
sind und dass Daniel
Joachim Sauer Sohn dabei ist und dann
möchte ich mich bei der Gelegenheit
natürlich ganz herzlich bei meinem Mann
bedanken denn er hatte vieles
auszuhalten vieles durchzustehen und
glücklicherweise hat er seine eigene
Leidenschaft die Wissenschaft das hat
manchmal geholfen glaube ich
und damit ich nicht im eigenen Saft
schmore was vielleicht eine der größten
Gefahren ist wenn man
Bundeskanzlerin ist und sich immer nur
mit diesem Tunnelblick um die täglichen
Ereignisse Schwert freue ich mich dass
zwei aus der Wissenschaft neben meinem
Mann natürlich dabei sind Helmut schwarz
und Robert Schlögl die mich so manchmal
erscheinen lassen als würde ich noch was
verstehen von dem was sie tun aber die
Wissenschaft hat mich immer fasziniert
und das ist auch so geblieben und es
sind Menschen da die mich in ganz
anderes Fähren entführt haben was ich
immer sehr genossen habe Horst Bredekamp
Neil McGregor Ulrich Matthes und Alena
Büchs
die mir einfach geholfen haben mal auf
über was anderes nachzudenken was
anderes schön zu finden mich heute heute
Zeit zu finden mich mit der Renaissance
zu beschäftigen
global zu denken wie wir es mit dem
Humboldt Forum vorhatten und vielleicht
immer noch vorhaben und
vieles andere was mich weiter
leidenschaftlich interessiert hat aber
für das sich nicht genug Zeit habe in
diesem Sinne stehen die jetzt
vorgestellten Personen nicht nur für den
heutigen Abend sondern sie stehen dafür
dass
ganz viele Menschen dazu gehören wenn
man 16 Jahre Bundeskanzler ist bei denen
kann ich mich jetzt nur auf diese Weise
Gedanken und einfach sagen
ich habe viele sehr sehr gute
Erfahrungen gemacht das heißt ja immer
Politik seien so schlimmes Ding und ich
wusste schon mir passiert was Ulrich
mattes habe ich natürlich als
Schauspieler vergessen der mir die Kunst
des Sprechens in meinem ein bisschen
beigebracht hat aber vielleicht hat die
ihn sogar schon erwähnt ja
aber trotzdem so wie auch immer
es wird ja oft gesprochen was für eine
Schlangengrube Politik ist ich darf
sagen ich hätte es nicht überlebt wenn
es nicht auch die andere Seite der
Politik gibt und deshalb konnte ich mir
auch immer Freunde machen danke schön
Herr Bundespräsident
ja das war eine lange Rede von
Bundespräsident Steinmeier und eine im
Vergleich dazu kurze danke sagen von
Angela Merkel und wir sehen hier noch
die Bilder wie Angela Merkel noch mal
nach vorne tritt mit ihrem Ehemann
Joachim Sauer es werden noch mal Fotos
gemacht irgendwo dort bei den Gästen
steht auch gesagt da Jürgen Klinsmann
der laut Frau Angela Merkel nicht ganz
so ins Bild passt sie aber während ihrer
Kanzlerschaft anscheinend begleitet hat
und über diese reden wollen wir
natürlich gleich noch mal sprechen wenn
ihr also fragen oder Gedanken zudem hat
was wir gerade gehört haben das war
wirklich eine ganze Menge dann schreibt
uns gerne hier in den Youtube Chat oder
per Mail hier sehen wir noch mal Frau
Merkel mit ihrem neuen wirklich
stattlichen Orden und ich gucke mal so
ein bisschen in die Kommentare was ihr
so denkt hier schreibt Sandra auf
Youtube sie hat Großartiges geleistet
und uns mit weiß ich in die Zukunft
geführt schaut was in anderen Ländern
los ist ich möchte über das was wir
gehört haben gerne noch mal mit meiner
Kollegin Nicole Diekmann sprechen die
uns jetzt wieder zugeschaltet ist
Nicole was ist dein erster Eindruck von
diesen reden zum einen von der Rede von
Bundespräsident Frank Walter Steinmeier
aber auch von der Danksagung von Angela
Merkel
der größte Unterschied du hast ihn eben
schon genannt der offensichtlichste ist
der Zeitfaktor Frank Walter Steinmeier
hat eine gute halbe Stunde geredet und
ich glaube Angela Merkel jetzt ein
bisschen länger als fünf Minuten und
wenn man ein bisschen mehr in die Tiefe
geht dann ist
besonders ins Auge gestorben natürlich
das fand weiter Steinmeier neben aller
Lobhudelei von Angela Merkel ihre
Eigenschaften da hat er drei genannt die
für ihn besonders herausgestochen haben
das waren auch Fakten
verhandlungs- und Kompromissbereitschaft
und und beierbarkeit da ist er dann doch
anschließend auch in die Tiefe gegangen
und hat unterschiedliche Themen
angesprochen er fängt an mit der
Bankenkrise mit der Euro-Krise mit
Corona das ja in weitesten Teilen noch
in die Amtszeit auch von Angela Merkel
gefallen ist und wir haben natürlich
alle drauf gewartet auch den Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine da sagte er
man müsse mit dem Blick auf das was
Vladimir Putin da getan habe dieser
Angriffskrieg dieser völkerrechtswidrige
Angriffskrieg heute anders denken und
die eigenen Positionen überprüfen das
war eine Vorlage da war man natürlich
sehr gespannt ob Angela Merkel darauf
eingehen würde und jetzt können wir
sagen nein das ist sie nicht denn sie
hat sich inhaltlich in ihrer Rede
überhaupt gar nicht geäußert sie ist die
Gästeliste durchgegangen sie hat
begründet wen sie eingeladen hat sie hat
sich bedankt auch bei ihrem Mann das war
ein relativ persönlicher Teil ihrer Rede
dafür ist ja auch nicht bekannt dass sie
das oft und gerne gemacht hat aber
ansonsten hat sie die Themen nicht mal
gestreift
ja das ist mir auch auf jeden Fall
aufgefallen es war wirklich nur ein Dank
an die versammelten Menschen die da
waren was mir auch noch aufgefallen ist
ist das natürlich Frank Walter
Steinmeier auch immer wieder
hervorgehoben hat dass Angela Merkel als
Politikerin gerne vom Ende her gedacht
hat ist aber bei bestimmten Themen
einfach schwer ist vom Ende her zu
denken das klingt für mich auch so ein
bisschen an wie eine Entschuldigung von
dem was viele gerade kritisieren ja
reicht dir das denn findest du das ist
eine ja begründbare
begründbare Argumentation für diesen
Orten viele in der Community bei uns
sind sehr kritisch und sagen ich weiß ja
nicht ob das für diesen Orden reicht wie
geht's dir da
also ich würde mir nicht anmaßen jetzt
zu beurteilen hat Angela Merkel diesen
Orden verdient oder nicht ich glaube was
man sagen kann ist dass Frank Walter
Steinmeier natürlich nichts anderes
übrig geblieben ist als eine sehr
lobende eine sehr warme
Rede auf Angela Merkel zu halten denn
ansonsten würde er sich selber ja
konterkarieren warum soll er jemanden
mal den höchsten deutschen Orden
verleihen von dem er denkt na ja das
hätte man sich vielleicht auch sparen
können ich glaube was man tatsächlich
einmal festhalten muss ist dass nichts
auf dieser Welt schwarz weiß ist es gibt
diejenigen ähm die Kritik üben an der
Verladung dieses Ordens ich habe das ja
vor dieser Veranstaltung als wir schon
mal gesprochen haben auch
zusammengefasst da ist ein Faktor der
Zeitpunkt da gibt es aber eben auch zum
Teil auch aus Angela Merkels eigener
Partei der CDU sehr
fundamentale inhaltliche Kritik die
atombänder dass er völlig überall
gewesen und natürlich vor allem ihre
Russland Politik aber es gibt
eben auch ganz offensichtlich genug
Menschen die der Ansicht sind eine
16-jährige Kanzlerschaft in die viele
Krisen gefallen sind eine hohe
Arbeitslosigkeit bei Amtsantritt die
Euro-Krise die Bankenkrise Corona da
habe Angela Merkel die sogenannte
flüchtlingskrise nicht zu vergessen da
habe Angela Merkel so viel
außerordentliches deshalb dieser Orden
fürs Land geleistet dass ihr dieser
Osten Orden zusteht das ist also eine
gemischte Gemengelage klar wir reden vor
allem über die Kritik aber es gibt eben
beide Seiten
Nicole vielen dank dir für deine
Einschätzung danke dass du bei uns warst
und wir schauen jetzt auch noch mal
rüber zu Dr Ursula Weidenfeld sie ist
ebenfalls Journalistin und Biografin von
Angela Merkel hallo Frau Weidenfeld
schön dass sie noch mal da sind
hallo auch an sie noch mal die Frage wie
haben Sie diese beiden ja sehr
unterschiedlichen reden wahrgenommen zum
einen die Begründung von Frank Walter
Steinmeier die Rede auf Angela Merkel
und eben gewissermaßen ihr Lebenswerk
und dann die sehr kurze Dankesrede von
Angela Merkel
ja das war schon ein echtes Schauspiel
fand ich also der Bundespräsident der
nun wirklich alles ausrollt was man an
Angela Merkel loben kann und vor allem
am Anfang damit dass man sie als Frau
lobt dass man sie als ostdeutschen
Routine für die sie nichts kann aber die
sie unten und die sie ehrlich gesagt
auch selten eingesetzt hat als
politisches Mittel aber die eben
natürlich da sind und dann hat er etwas
gesagt was das fand ich total
total papierend weil er sagt Angela
Merkel habe Deutschland 16 Jahre
Wirtschaftswachstum nahezu
ununterbrochenes Wirtschaftswachstum
spendiert und das zeigt finde ich die
merkwürdig mal an diese zeitwagen nimmt
weil es ist eigentlich die Zeit mit den
tiefsten Wirtschaftskrisen die
Deutschland die erlebt hat -5,5 % in der
Finanzkrise -4% in der Krone Krise also
schlimmer geht's eigentlich nicht und
dass man das wahrnimmt als eigentlich
doch ganz gute prosperierende Zeit geht
das zeigt für dich das große Talent ja
Kanzlerin der ehemaligen der alte
Bundeskanzlerin eben Dinge
unspektakulär abzuarbeiten auch wenn sie
super spektakulär sind das hat Frank
Walter Steinmeier erwähnt er hat das hat
Nicole Diekmann für mich sehr sehr schön
auch ausgearbeitet nämlich zu sagen er
hatte ja eigentlich dann den Teppich
ausgerollt um zu sagen es tut mir auch
leid es war wirklich blöd von uns diese
Nummer mit der Ukraine und die
fehlereinschätzung von Russland das
hätten wir auch anders machen müssen
darauf ist sie gar nicht eingestiegen
und sie ist erstaunlicherweise gar nicht
also ich fand es auch super geschickt
weil sie sie hat ja im Grunde das
gemacht was jeder bei der Goldene
Hochzeit macht er stellte Gäste vor und
er sagte das die haben mir da geholfen
die waren damals zu mir und da habe ich
Grund zur Dankbarkeit und eben auch zu
erklären warum möglicherweise der ein
oder andere nicht da ist das macht man
wenn man selber nichts Bedeutendes sagen
will also eigentlich super gerissen
super schlau und ehrlich gesagt ich fand
auch man hat ja Angela Merkel immer
nachgesagt sie haben wirklich gar keinen
kein rhetorisches Talent das hat sie
heute finde ich also durch diese doch so
eine listige Arzt sich um die Fakten zu
drücken er hat sie doch irgendwie wieder
lieb ich fand das sehr sehr nett
ja wir haben es gerade angesprochen
Frank Walter Steinmeier hat viel über
die Identität Angela Merkels gesprochen
die sie selber ja gar nicht so oft wie
Sie richtig sagen eingesetzt hat was mir
auch noch aufgefallen ist ist so diese
starke hervorheben von Frau Merkels
Leistung in diesen Finanzkrisen ne also
gerade auch was den europäischen
Zusammenhalt angeht da hat er ja auch
versucht so eine Art Tradition
eigentlich zu zu Kohle herzustellen oder
ja und ich finde dass er da auf den
Punkt den hatte so unter einen von
vielen Punkten genannt aber das ist
wirklich der entscheidende Punkt der 16
Jahre Angela Merkel sie hat Europa
zusammengehalten sie hat Europa in
wirklich kritischen Phasen und das war
in der Finanzkrise superkritisch es war
in der Euro kriegskrise superkritisch
und dann eben auch noch mal in der
corona-pandemie in diesem Phasen hat sie
es geschafft das Europa zusammengehalten
hat dass 2015 in dieser Nacht in der
Alex aufgestanden ist und gesagt hat das
war's wir verlassen in Euro sie ist
hinter dem her und hat gesagt komm wir
reden noch mal und am Morgen hat sie
Europa und hat sie den Euro
zusammengehalten wir haben das damals
alle sehr sehr kritisch kommentiert und
ich auch das hat man nicht so gesehen
wie sie sich im Nachhinein da
herausgestellt hat aber da muss man eben
schon sagen es hat so ein paar
Situationen gegeben in denen sie am Ende
recht behalten hat und das ist das eine
davon und das muss man und das hat der
Bundespräsident finde ich zurecht auch
herausgestellt
wir haben jetzt hier abschließend noch
mal eine Frage aus der Community Nicole
Diekmann hat es gerade schon gesagt es
ist wenig schwarz-weiß in dieser Welt
vielleicht trotzdem noch mal als Klammer
diese Frage von youtube hat Angela
Merkel denn jetzt gleiches oder
annähernd vergleichbares geleistet wie
ein Kohle oder Adenauer welche den Orden
ja auch verliehen bekommen haben
das finde ich ähm wo man wusste es bei
Konrad Adenauer als er den Orden
bekommen hat wussten
vier Jahre nach der Gründung der
Bundesrepublik das ging mal gerade so
alles einigermaßen wieder gut es
Wirtschaftswunder fing gerade an Fahrt
aufzunehmen ob am Ende diese Wette
aufgehen würde der Westbindung und auch
am Ende dieses Ende des 1990 die
deutsche Einheit stehen würde das wusste
kein Mensch wir waren mitten im Kalten
Krieg und die größten Krisen der
Adenauer schon best Politik waren auch
noch gar nicht durchgestanden insofern
haben wir damals vielleicht in der
ähnlichen und hätten wir wenn wir damals
ähnlich kommentiert hätten
wahrscheinlich ähnlich gefragt ist das
richtig ist es nicht zu früh ist es ähm
angemessen bei Helmut Kohl dasselbe
helmut Kohl hat den Orden in den letzten
Tagen seine Amtszeit bekommen
bevor alle wussten das ist eine
Parteispendenaffäre geben würde das ist
einen eine wirklich zersetzende
Auseinandersetzung mit Wolfgang Schäuble
gehen würde dass die CDU wirklich
jahrelang am Boden lag und eben von
dieser besagten Angela Merkel die heute
berühmt wurde wieder wieder
zusammengepuzzelt werden musste das
wussten wir damals alles auch nicht und
damals hätte man vermutlich mit dem
Wissen von heute oder von zwei Jahren
später sich auch gefragt muss das jetzt
sein heute werden wir wieder viel
gnädiger und würden sagen ja klar Helmut
Kohl ein großer Kanzler der Kanzler der
Einheit und die Partei Spendenaffäre das
kann man ja davon nachlässigen und
ähnlich wird es vermutlich auch mit
Angela Merkel gegen dass man vielleicht
in fünf oder zehn Jahren wenn so dieser
dieser Prozess des Vergessens der ja
auch wirklich wahnsinnig gnädig ist
gerade in der Politik wenn dieser
Prozess eingesetzt hat wenn wir viel
viel von dem was wir heute noch
nachtragen nachsortieren vielleicht
vergessen oder auch vergeben haben dann
wird man wahrscheinlich anders auf diese
kanzlerinnenschaft gucken und
möglicherweise dann auch zu dem Stand zu
dem zu dem Standpunkt kommen das war
jetzt doch übertrieben nur weil es die
erste Frau und die erste ostdeutsche war
hätte sie den Ohren nicht kriegen müssen
aber ich würde mal vermuten dass man im
Rückblick immer großzügiger ist als in
der Zeit wo Geschichte noch qualmt und
wo man noch viele viele alte und offene
Rechnungen da liegen hat auf die man
täglich schaut
ja das ist doch ein ganz schöner
Ausblick in die Zukunft wir werden auf
jeden Fall weiter dran bleiben wie sich
das Vermächtnis von Angela Merkel
vielleicht über die Zeit noch entwickelt
Frau Weidenfeld vielen Dank dass Sie bei
uns waren unsere Fragen beantwortet
haben
super gerne tschüss tschüss ich gucke
zum Schluss noch mal in Eure Kommentare
und die Meinung bei euch sind weiterhin
geteilt die hier sagt jemand ich höre
jetzt hier in der Rede von Frankfurt da
stand mal eben nichts was in
herausragenderweise diese Verleihung
rechtfertigen würde sie auf eine Ebene
mit Adenauer und cool zu stellen ist ein
schlechter Vergleich und dann gibt's
aber auch Stimmen die sagen sie hat
ihren Job ganz gut gemacht war auch im
Ausland recht beliebt ob es deswegen
gleich eine Medaille geben muss sei mal
dahingestellt also gemischte Meinung und
euch sollte jemals wieder ein Kanzler
oder eine Kanzlerin diesen Orden
verlieren bekommen ich bin mir sicher
dann machen wir wieder eine Sendung dazu
bis dahin erstmal einen schönen Abend
und bis dann